Tucker Carlson is back amazingly as of
tonight there aren't many platforms left
that allow Free Speech the last big one
remaining in the world the only one is
Twitter starting soon we'll be bringing
a new version of the show we've been
doing for the last six and a half years
to Twitter to the context here is not
just that okay Tucker is going to start
streaming on Twitter the context is that
Tucker is going to break his contract
with Fox News Fox took him off the air
Fox didn't exactly fire him he's still
being paid millions and millions and
millions of dollars reports are that he
is still owed out about 26 million
dollars on his Fox contract which he's
willing to break to go on and bring you
the news and the reports that you're not
seeing on other shows on the one
platform that will allow you to do it
that would be Twitter